o lado pessoal de quem fala é o dar que
seja muito bem vindo ser mais um vídeo e
ou estragos equipe era nosso jogo é este
porque estamos dentro de uma casa de
banho tem um pessoal nós temos é que
oscar book médio e pra quem tem
acompanhado este sério vocês sabem que o
significado na noite 6 não viajou passei
noites em jaipur à noite 7 que
supostamente era tipo uma versão do
aluno assim e basicamente o jogo
utilizou o que quer dizer que o produziu
saiu por deus faria supor que tudo vamos
cansar da noite um supostamente isso
jogando aqui por uma versão faces podem
andar na casa do big man fora do que um
quarto o que é brutal por isso eu não me
importo do tempo livre s6 nós começamos
na casa de banho o que não é nada
assustador nada para entrar tudo muito
mais bonito as lutas estão melhores
junto a ficar muito boa série e no
twitter que o time qualquer coisa na
escada aparentemente está chovendo lá
fora da província de gotas na água né eu
posso pagar a luz aqui o eu posso pagar
a luz até aqui temos aqui interações
também ok vamos lá ver se consigo abrir
suas portas esta não abre o texto também
não abro meu de lá está tudo escuro e o
fofo né né
tem que estas casas eu não sei se eu
devia tinha já a emtu grupo marrom ok eu
preciso ir pro meu quarto posto mas não
saiu daqui o quarto nem precisem chegar
a casa dessa equipe é tão louco não
deixa a mulher possa fluir alguém aqui
qualquer coisa para não ter um código
que eu preciso deixar esse código para
abrir esta porta supostamente isso o
resto o pendor salta isso já sabe
vamos lá então à procura do código sport
também tem lá embaixo nem será que está
dentro deste sexto não está o era eu não
conseguir porque além do grupo my room
eu não consigo passar aqui de escala não
sei porquê mas 4 deve ficar em cima
então essa tá aberta em agosto mais um
psf twitter a equipe é que o quarto
treino sai ou na ituano oca estamos nos
quartos construído agora vamos chegar à
noite um outra vez nem isso parece está
igual 15 acontece o cabo usb
dentro do quarto eu acho que parece tudo
igual como estava antes eu acho que eles
não mandaram que nada é não seja
texturas calhar esta noite um país fácil
muito fácil dominar visto com
secretários rápido e não tenho certeza
mas acho que cada no espaço vocês têm
acesso a mais partes da casa o que
entretanto vamos saber se é assim mesmo
que funciona em um estudo na garagem é
ter feito isso a oferta está tranqüila
furar o barco sai da janela sabe que por
onde apurou já chega pronto pode escalar
um cão ótimo não quer saber e não quer
saber agora eu vou ficar atenta mesmo
porque eu não sei o que é que incluíram
neste planeta não sei se tem algum novo
aqui eu duvido muito que na primeira
noite time né mas vamos lá pelo chão ao
cair 5 e 50
estamos prestes e olga e ficou da linha
conseguiu expulsar a estudante pessoal e
vemos um mercado novo o que já parece
uma coisa em cima de save
isso é novo achou é por cima ao novo
caiu aqui nós temos aqui então ajuda na
casa né manter as luzes acesas vai tomar
é o quarto seguro aqui também diz que o
tempo ter certeza que eu não uso isso
nenhuma inspiração quando estou a andar
baixo de intenções nem sabem que o meu
inglês tamanho bom tenta encontrar aí
temos pela casa pra te ajudar quando
tudo faz para o quarto é aparentemente
também a casa escolhida pela casa e tem
que usar para ouvir quando quando chegar
o quarto mais uma vez lembra de onde
estão os interruptores de luz na
escuridão não é tua amiga blá blá blá
não faz parabéns mas se não for mesmo
necessário né e conhecimento então vai
ser o nosso tempo city para ir para o
que eu disse aqui eu preciso de uma
flash lite é isso que o jogo está a
melhorar dois tanto espera mesmo que
discutirão em fazer updates da brutal
vazios casa dele fora tá tudo muito bem
feito pra gastar em friday só este chuva
que não está bem feita né não citar
abrir esta porta não era possível ter a
porta vaca é sobre isso não faço barulho
buckman dalila por enquanto é que
estamos bem porque a luz do game é não
há nem se diz chan o vírus embora a
memória não houve nada porque pelo que
eu tenho que manter o título e se é isso
eu te conheço
abraão
aí eu tô aqui
ai ai sua vida espiritual em cima meu
caso da menina
tudo escuro e eu não vou entrar em
contato diz que não espera votar a lei
facilita na hora que tem que vir um
grupo de metal e fosse para um estado
que fosse para que tenhamos ficando um
pouco menor na casa do baile vamos
aproveitar então pra ir até lá abaixo
anda concordar que sai das casas com uma
escada está escuro neste quadro foi um
dos que me apanhou por isso vamos ter
muita calma aqui
ae burle meu eu já não vou entrar na
nave uma pronta portanto que o que
existe é que 500 você não sabe por isso
é a sala de jantar supostamente opa tá
tudo escuro e não é muito seguro andar
aqui dentro é quente que eu saiba esta
porta dá acesso ao jardim mostra saídas
ou alguma coisa assim do gênero ainda
fica escura que não tem medo de entrar
aqui se não dissermos que ganhou
carreira como flash of flies high tech
flash está aqui aprendi foi que agora um
declínio foi só isso aí eu posso levar
uma faca e segurança dilma estuda quem
pelo menos usar
vocês já viram está a fui cadeira e
queima numa cadeira baixo como assim
eu entro que litro o caiaque a luxa que
ela está tranquilo está favorável abre
essa porta
o timão só vão chegar porque o espírito
como sempre vou contar com a vossa ajuda
nem nos comentários que eu tenho que
fazer como é que eu posso jogar como é
que o egito bugmann é escuro como
affleck favorito fiquem bem está próximo